esta vez la ofensiva conservadora
funcionó
se reanuda la sesión con una votación de
27 a favor y 19 en contra el senado está
de acuerdo con la enmienda de la cámara
Amén tras varios intentos el senado de
Carolina del Sur votó a favor de la
prohibición de abortar después de las
seis semanas de embarazo esta medida
limitará drásticamente el acceso a la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo ya
que a menudo en esta fase de la
concepción muchas mujeres ignoran que
están embarazadas sin embargo desde hace
varios meses las cinco senadoras de la
asamblea de todas las tendencias
políticas han hecho campaña contra este
texto
siento rabia siento frustración es tan
descorazonador ver que aquí 41 hombres
pueden tomar decisiones que van a
afectar a las mujeres y niñas de nuestro
estado durante generaciones
desde que el tribunal supremo de rogó El
fallo Row versus White el año pasado
unos 15 estados han restringido el
derecho al aborto Carolina del Sur se
había convertido en Un refugio para
muchas mujeres que viven en Estados
vecinos donde el aborto está prohibido
en Twitter el gobernador del estado es
republicano Henry mccaster dijo que
esperaba promulgar la ley cuanto antes
esta noche nuestro estado está un paso
más cerca de proteger vidas inocentes
espero firmar esta ley lo antes posible
la noticia fue denunciada por grupos de
Derechos Humanos algunos ya han
prometido emprender acciones legales